before we say goodbye we like to play a
quick round out truth or dare
and we have today christina yanus hi
christina hi guys hi
cute fitting in our color story today
look at that
thank you thank you yeah
all right what's it going to be a truth
or a dare i'm going to pick drew okay
okay so my truth is is have either of
you ever done an irish exit such as
leaving a party or an event without
saying goodbye to anyone and if so when
is that rude
yes i think it is a little okay actually
i think it depends on the size and i
will tell you why if you're at an
intimate dinner party
i think uh an exit without saying thank
you and goodbye is totally weird if
you're at a large party what are you
gonna do tell everybody make a whole 30
minutes of it i totally agree with you
100 if it's intimate you know you go
around you give the hug you do the thing
but if you're at a big thing and i can't
find you i got to go
90 day fiance is on at home i have
things to do
what do you think christina when was the
last time you did that or do you frown
upon such behavior oh i
actually do it all the time it's
horrible
wait all the time a decent amount i feel
like it's bad but i do it my mom and i
do it a lot when we go to family parties
we have a big family and
it takes like and we're gonna say
goodbye it's gonna take an hour so we're
just gonna leave yeah yeah and here's
the move right hey i looked for you to
say goodbye but i couldn't find you
that is good and diabolical right but it
works you also can definitely send a
text to saying
i had the best time thank you so much
like that night because you know they're
not really checking it until the next
day and then you look like that guy who
like did some toe dip in in some format
yeah all right well good good i hope
that helped yes thank you you're welcome
thank you
we want to thank you for choosing you to
spend your time with us
and we make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you